speaking of weirdos and interviews uh
have you seen this video by the good
liars this one here it's so hard to keep
up i feel like this one this one's a gem
as you see here uh this guy here i told
you earlier this has got jfk enter
junior enters the chat if you look here
he's wearing a shirt that says trump
plus jfk junior 2021
so his shirt that he's wearing to this
rally is already outdated um these
people i don't get it 2021 like do they
think that there was a special election
that was going to happen i don't know
where jfk junior all of a sudden went
and became a conservative these are all
good questions these are all really
really good hard-hitting questions these
are the questions i try to avoid but
somehow you make me ask them tony right
exactly well this is how it works and it
looks like a husband and wife bear here
i'm not really sure their relation
please don't procreate well but they're
asking
they're asking
you mean jfk junior and this guy or
these the husband oh just these two like
you know i'm just well i'm just you know
couple brain cells rubbing together here
right but this appears to be um
outside the gated parking area as we
know they gain in the parking areas now
they lock you in you can't leave leave
the rallies we've heard that from the
defense and that's got barbed wire right
yeah they're definitely looks like a
prison almost like a trump prison but
listen listen to the dialogue and listen
uh listen to the theories because you've
seen the video where the person thought
that princess diana was still alive
right you've seen that one yep yeah yeah
yeah okay now listen to what this that
was on and that was on the uh that was
on a news station right for
uh right or rsbn or whatever right they
were airing it as if it was news yeah
they're like hey this is good listen to
what this lady says about
joe biden and jim carrey i think she's
watching too many movies and getting
movies confusion
listen here listen you think biden is
not alive right now no the guy that's
doing the stand-up job of trying to wake
people up is an actor wearing a mask i
mean he's an actor wearing a mask okay
so he's got a mask on jim carrey did
play biden on snl
right and he did do a movie called the
mask the mask but listen in listen in
several different people playing joe
biden at this point and then when when
he fell up the stairs going on the
airplane
so you remember the video yeah yeah i
remember the wind was
he kind of stumbles a bit he struggles
to get you know
joe biden isn't is an old guy but he
doesn't struggle to go down a ramp or
really up a ramp he doesn't go sometimes
you trip on the stairs right i mean this
is a presidential moment that happens a
lot i mean you can drink with water with
one hand
right right he can use right only one
hand i have a good story after the show
for you gabe that we might we might do
something with this about uh and well
we'll have to do that but i don't want
to give it away on air but anyways
the moment a lot of people don't
understand like an airport there's a lot
of wind right and and they always have
open steps to get into air force one
they're not hooked to the terminal or
anything right and and there's a lot of
wind so a lot of times when you're
coming down or going upstairs there's a
lot of wins so if you stumble but here's
the thing
is listen to who she thinks actually
stumbled it was joe biden i'll admit
that but listen who she thinks it was
they swapped i myself think that that
was jim carrey i've heard that he was
one of them
good night goodbye i'm done this this
lady this lady thinks that jim carrey is
the one
who who fell down the steps
um or fell up the step whatever
again she's getting she's getting a
couple things confused here listen to
the question he asked
wait wait wait wait you think that jim
carrey was wearing a mask
and was the acting president and being
silly by falling up the stairs three
different times she literally she's
watching footage of the president united
states she's watching snl as you alluded
to that jim carrey plays joe biden on
snl and then she's watching the movie
the mask i think
and she's really kind of getting these
things they watch way too many [ __ ]
movies man these crazy wackadoo q and on
folks watch way
too much tv they watch way too many
movies it is absolutely insane it gets
it gets better gabe it gets better
it gets so much better here
and james woods also i think is one of
them
james woods is a is a biden actor oh
that's what she's saying that's what
she's saying that's what she's saying
here at the end listen uh let me pull it
back let me pull it back here listen
and james woods also i think is one of
the
doppelganger mask wearing
people
so here's the thing here's the thing
james woods and jim carrey are
doppelgangers with mask on which is not
doppelgangers are not
they don't i i don't know if you know
what doppelganger means but
james woods is a conservative he is
right trump
humping conservative but gabe who better
to play joe biden than someone who would
implement the policies that you'd want
to implement so when gas when gas prices
go up wait no no no no no no that was
that no that was yeah that was
that was jim carrey doing that that was
jim carrey playing joe biden got it got
it okay oh my [ __ ] god this is
this is what we have to contend with and
and really honestly i i said this uh
before you came in the year
these people are getting dumber and
dumber and dumber at his rallies and
it's not surprising that the the dumb is
staying with him and the people who
aren't completely [ __ ] delusional and
lost their minds and just off their
rockers are starting to peel away from
him that's why i believe we're seeing
dumber and dumber at his rallies
not to be confused with the jim carrey
movie dumb and dumber but it is it is
starting to leak into fantasy really
i
yeah i just i knew it would leave you
speechless i don't even know what like
you you you listen to that and you go
what
right like there's no there's no other
way to be like oh like is she is she
punking
like the big the the good liars like is
that what she's doing you know and it's
like no this is actually someone who
legitimately 100
lives in a reality where she believes
biden isn't really biden or has actors
who are playing biden which is a
comedian known as jim carrey and a
right-wing nut job former actor uh
uh straight to dvd james woods who you
know it's like it doesn't make any sense
it well is it supposed to that's the
thing here again i've said this over and
over again we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life and on one s
on one corner there's the facebook
ivermectin group and the on the other
corner is the q anon headquarters i just
feel like soon it's just becoming 100
wrestlemania like that's what like there
is no really yeah
and there is no intersection it's just
uh it's just uh it's straight or
somebody somebody at one point was like
hey maybe this is a two-way and they're
like no it's a one-way one-way dirt road
kiwi non avenue